Aaron: So the transparent screen is showing
performance footage of the same slideshow
we’re showing in the gallery.
When the performance was shot, the white balance
was created in such a way that it adds a blue
tinge to the slides, so basically our choice
now is—if we want them to match—do we
try to add a blue tinge to the wall?
Or do we try to remove the blue from the footage?
Leah: Oh, I don’t think we should make the
slides blue.
That would be…
Charlie: No, they’re beautiful in black
and white.
Aaron: So I think we should look at maybe
trying to desaturate the performance footage
and try to get them to work better together
that way.
Leah: Well, I think we should test it in the
space though just to see…
Charlie: I brought my computer because I have
everything laid out on my computer…
Leah: You know, my instinct is to keep the
color because it tells you it’s something
different, you know, and that it’s live.
Charlie: Well, if you look at it in the wide
shot you’ll see…
That’s when it’s really blue.
But everything is blue, that’s the thing.
The floor is blue.
Leah: I see what you’re talking about.
The one thing that I do like about having
it in color is that it keeps some sense that
it’s different in character from the slide
projection, that it’s a continually re-performed
work, and this is one…
But I wonder if we can get it less blue and
keep the sense of it being in color or whether
you think that really the only way we can
make it work is to…
Charlie: Well, you can desaturate it and everything
gets desaturated and it’s still color.
Leah: Well, Charlie, I’m going to leave
that decision to you.
Charlie: I’m not that bothered by the fact
that it’s blue versus this—because it
is two different things.
But I was just trying to make it match…
Aaron: Well, we certainly don’t want people
to think that this is one piece that is being
staged in a gallery.
Leah: Yeah, and the more discrepant things
are, the more it seems like maybe we should
just try to tell people that this is how it
looks in the context of a performance.
Mack: And what about that?
Leah: What about what?
Aaron: There will be some spill.
Mack: It will be like this more than like
this, but…
Leah: You mean spill on the floor?
Aaron: Yeah, but you see that bottom right
corner which is representative of the actual…
Leah: I don’t know…
Charlie: I like it.
Mack: It looks really good there.
Charlie: Yeah.
I’m just wondering if you want to put something
on the floor to make it even, but maybe not…
Leah: Actually the colors on the floor are
pretty good!
Mack: The issue is that you see the keystoning
on the floor.
Charlie: I like that.
I mean, that’s what happens when you project
from above…
Aaron: I mean, this is two layers of the film,
so actually if you look at one layer it will
then be much more on the floor.
And it’s a little sharper because the two
layers soften it just a touch—soften the
edges.
Leah: Can we try it that way, and if we change
our minds we add another layer?
Aaron: Sure.
Leah: Okay.
Yeah, I love it actually.
I really love it.
I think people are just going to stay here
mesmerized.